avoir des rapports de type sexuel c'est
un peu comme conduire un camion la
première est un peu dure à passer mais
après ça roule tout seul et c'est nul
comme comparaison ça n'en avoir des
rapports de type sexuel c'est plutôt
comme la raclette
si on aime bien ça aix est bien préparé
c'est quand même vachement bon mais
attention au riz attention parce que de
la jouissance aux urgences il a parfois
qu'un pas alors laissez-moi vous mettre
en garde avec ce top des accidents qui
vous guette si vous pratiquez le poli
[Musique]
premier drame de la population la
fracture de la verge la verge ou [ __ ]
pénis zigounette temps la verge donc
c'est pas un os mais ça peut casser ça
arrive généralement pendant un rapport
sexuel de type fougue voir un peu
alcoolisé et particulièrement quand la
personne qui possède le pénis n'a pas le
contrôle du mouvement
c'est à dire quand il est en dessous
dans la moitié des cas dans ce qu'on
appelle un faux pas du coït le membre
viril sort entièrement de l'orifice dans
lequel il se trouvait et vient heurter
une partie du corps plus dur en sus un
grand crac et la lbu gêné seront alors
la lbu jeunesse et par légumes et la
capsule qui entoure le corps caverneux
du pénis qui est gorgée de sang pendant
l'érection
autant vous dire qu'en cas de fractures
l'érection elle disparaît instantanément
et que le sang se répand partout sous la
peau ce qui donne à l'organe une allure
potagères comme cole légumes on y vient
finalement bref dans ces cas là il faut
placer tout ça dans la glace filet à
l'hôpital se faire opérer puis laisser
le petit blessés tranquille pendant six
semaines
six semaines attention ne pas confondre
la fracture de la verge et la rupture du
frein
j'avais le petit bouton qui relie le
gland prépuce et qui peut lâcher aussi
ça saigne à l'extérieur cette fois il
faut aussi souvent se faire opérer c'est
plus impressionnant mais c'est moins
grave le pénis n'est pas le seul organe
à se montrer facétieux le vagin ne
laisse pas sa part au chien en matière
d'espièglerie il peut par exemple se
contracter violemment et emprisonnés ce
qui se trouve à l'intérieur comme un
sextoy une langue pourquoi pas ou le
plus souvent un pénis la mésaventure
répond alors le nom de syndrome du pénis
captifs c'est sans danger mais ce n'est
pas très confortable surtout si on se
rend à un rendez vous professionnel pour
mettre fin à la prise d'otages il faut
avoir quelques notions d'anatomie et
savoir que les muscles en cause sont les
releveurs de l'anus il se présente sous
la forme d'un double 8 dont les boucles
entourent l'anus et le vagin est ce
qu'il faut surtout savoir c'est que les
boucles ne peuvent pas se contracter en
même temps l'astuce consiste donc à
relâcher celle qui est autour du vagin
en contractant celle de l'anus et pour
ça je vous fais pas de dessin avec un
doigt d'imagination vous devriez être
capable de trouver tout seul
l'avion à nice et l'ouzbékistan de la
sexualité c'est pas la zone la plus
visitée pourtant elle regorge de trésors
être surprise les vrais savent mais on
fait comme on aime qu'on sait encore
moins c'est que la région débouche sur
une zone qu'on appelle le rectum qu'à la
forme d'une ampoule est qu'à la fâcheuse
tendance à stocker tout ce qu'on lui
confie il n'est donc pas rare de voir
arriver aux urgences une personne mal à
l'aise qui boîte un peu et qui a
toujours une explication très crédible
sur la façon dont sa bougie parfumée
s'est trouvé coincé dans son ampoule
rectal alors je dis une bougie mais ça
peut être une réplique de statuettes des
oscars ou une boule à neige sur internet
à une base de données très documenté sur
la question
j'irai voir si vous voulez un vrai vide
greniers dans le jargon on appelle ça
des corps étrangers du rectum alors
attention il n'y a pas de mal à se faire
du bien mais sachez quand même que si
les médecins n'arrivent pas à retirer
l'objet où je l'aide mal ça peut finir
au bloc opératoire douleur après le coït
rougeurs et des démangeaisons et si ça
n'était pas une infection
et si c'était une allergie au sperme et
oui ça existe et ça arrive à tout âge et
même après plusieurs années de relation
avec le même partenaire
une allergologues m'a même raconté
qu'une de ses passions de 60 ans a fini
en réanimation après un oedème
généralisée et un choc allergique au
sperme celui de son mari en l'occurrence
alors tout s'est bien terminé et la
brave femme a même pu suivre un
traitement de désensibilisation
vous savez comme pour les allergiques
aux pollens quand on leur injecte un
tout petit peu de pollen sous la peau
pour que leur corps apprennent à se
défendre
voilà bah pareil sauf que là ce n'est
pas du pollen qu'on injecte sous la peau
voilà ce top est terminée surtout
continuer à pratiquer la sexualité que
vous aimez si vous aimez ça la peur
n'évite pas le danger et chaque problème
a sa solution et chacun voit midi à sa
porte
à 14h et abonnez-vous à dtc à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]